how's boom razor HP welcome back to the
exciting finale of The Walking Dead
let's do this bro you'd think they'd
starve long ago honestly
hey I'm talking to you what it's it's
what what do you mean what the place
you're [ __ ] taking us
he doesn't speak much English yeah no
[ __ ] is that it I thought you said it
was a house arvo is this where the
supplies are where the food is way
through god damn it no it's the house
you still walk this guy [ __ ] us thank
you
don't mention it I'm gonna have to stop
here maybe we should stop for the night
this is [ __ ] lakhs don't tell me to
relax
he's lying he's been lying this whole
time no [ __ ] know that
Luke needs a break probably all do look
I'll do whatever you guys want okay but
I could use the rest it'd be safer to
rest in there where there's a fence yeah
that's not bad actually
I feel like they need it yeah that
sounds an ass yeah yeah it does
oh sorry about that it's all right buddy
it's all right if we're staying we
should Scout this place out
all right y'all wait here I'll go make
sure this ain't some walk Ernest we're
locking ourselves in - I'll go with you
I'm see if see if you can calm it down a
bit that appearance got this in the bag
all right lemme clue clamby clue clamby
clue I'll probably do this ah I think he
likes you who doesn't like me come on
let's be honest calmed right down for
you it's cute high sex cute he is isn't
he most babies are pretty ugly this soon
after being born Hey they usually look
like weird little aliens here I got him
come on over it's safe well that was
fast
of the sky it's so proud I can't imagine
how freaking freezing it must be to
sleep outside even if you have a fire
like it must be insanely cold
come on he's gonna freeze he's my
birthday here as I can tell at least
well happy birthday Luke yeah man happy
birthday uh
can you even tell been keeping track of
the days been a few times I wasn't sure
I'd see my next birthday
well you did it guess that's worth
celebrating so that makes you what
twenty-seven that's that's right I'm
surprised you remember sure as hell feel
a lot older don't even start with that
[ __ ]
ha ha ha ha got out of college five
years ago feels like a million years at
least I don't have to worry about paying
off them student loans
I hear that [ __ ] sitting on that
paperwork waiting to collect uh-huh
probably what did you study
I majored in art history that's cool
sounds like you majored in working in a
coffee yeah how's much I would stop it
they get a minor in agriculture keep the
old man happy
oh we're saving it for a special
occasion and all it being your birthday
and all figure this is as good a time as
any I catch up where did you get it bale
kept all the alcohol in the armory he
didn't like people and by bit what's
that mean
drinking hey you didn't think people
should drink feel a little guilty taking
the first oh wait you got to make a
toast I'm not really the yeah come on
birthday boy it don't have to be fancy a
toast means we all got something to
drink oh we can just pass the bottle
around afterwards yeah
to the loved ones that we've lost along
the way and to the hope that we see them
again someday
you're here that was real nice
yeah I didn't mean for it to rhyme well
yeah young Saint asked watch
I think the fence has got us pretty
secure can't beat you careful baby might
be cold now I'll keep him warm
he's a tough little guy come on Kenny
just sit a little while longer now you
stay warm clean let him go I'm gonna
post up over near the hole in the fence
there holler if you need anything
thanks Kenny
fires real nice plenty of room if you
want to get warm
I didn't expect her to come back just
when I thought I got her figured out she
up in surprises it's a good thing she
saved our ass I
I know I just don't know what she's
getting at all
we're lucky to have her yeah I'm glad
she's here me too
well she helped us back there so that
puts her is okay in my book
oh come on I'm just teasing maybe the
birthday Schanke I understand she's a
pretty girl
once you get past all the dirt and birds
I don't know I guess I just wanted to
forget about all this [ __ ] for like ten
minutes ten minutes come on we got a
little one around
that's gross it's my fault for bringing
it up that's gross
yes it is clam we shouldn't be talking
about it she's still a kid I don't know
maybe she came back for you could be
I don't know what to say to that I come
back for you that was awkward
Thank You CLE I do the same Erica
Luke's irregular Casson though hey shut
up don't be modest your moves are
working on all the latest no wait what I
just did it who didn't I
sorry it's the drink talking they say a
drunk man talk as a sober man's thoughts
I ain't a man so they can take that [ __ ]
somewhere else clam go see if you can
get Jane and Kenny over by the fire it's
too cold for them to be out there
oh and here maybe a swig of this and
change the mouth have a swing I got a
peek all right I'm back let's talk to
these people girl let's have some booze
with this truce Balderrama I'm wrong the
best they expect you to lure me over
there with alcohol I mean I would
expected a bottle the lastest on it's
probably been a while for everyone will
at work that depends what is it it's
from probably
[Music]
Captain Jack Sparrow's right now exactly
where did that rump that I don't know on
it I'm sorry
so she do like him she wasn't expecting
to you know it'll only be weird if you
make it weird
just be cool hang out I wish it was that
easy it is people just love making it
harder than it has to be why does this
feel like I'm signing a contract or
something
that's really good have you had any
what's it it's okay um sure
I feel like with all this [ __ ] she's
gone through having a sip of alcohol
isn't gonna take that back I wasn't too
much older than you when I had my first
drink god I was so stupid back then
there was this time I broke into my
parents liquor cabinet and drank a whole
bottle of this really spicy sweet liquor
what was its name I was dumb earthquake
or something like you were a bad kid
something like you threw up a line at
the bottom of the bottle there were
these sugar crystals and I got it in my
head that I really wanted to eat a
couple so I got the bright idea to smash
it on my parents dining room floor to
get at him and it shattered into a
thousand pieces all over I think they
need them that's really stupid yeah I
was drunk a problem with glasses it
looks a lot like sugar crystals that's
not really don't keep it that way my
sister found me drunk blood pouring out
of my life the [ __ ] was in that he
thought I was dying so she called 9-1-1
they pumped my stomach [ __ ] ever
that doesn't make any sense here that
guy needs a drink more than any of us
over the old time and not yeah weird I
don't know
I'm Clement clove watch my shoes oh it
got weird
no that's I'm fine
oh yeah okay
wherever you like
Sugoi Sugoi let's talk a little bit to
claim me clue
I mean candy cool Kenny my man how you
doing
wanna drink huh you want some of these
no well what for me then hey well let's
try talking to Ken he's so nice with the
baby he's such an ass Oh
otherwise I'm starting to think she
might be a bad influence on you girl
your age ain't right no you think you're
older but you're not really
I didn't mean to disappoint you you're
not Hana he's probably not my place to
be telling you what to do
hey that is actually bad for younger to
drink especially because your brain
isn't as developed and just alcohol
kills brain cells so to do it early has
higher consequences that's why there's
the drinking limit not only give them
well I'm just I couldn't handle it I'm
sorry I mean you did what she could you
tried to help and I blamed you for it
I'm so so sorry I could have done more
no don't say that you did everything you
could
I'm sorry anything I said made you feel
any different than that it just makes me
feel awful I know I can be a real [ __ ]
sometimes
yep stop no it's true but I
I miss my boy I miss him so much
I didn't raise him like I should have
made mistakes wasn't they're all out for
a couple years off on a boat somewhere
or other I thought I enjoyed that time
away from him from my family I'd give
anything for one more second with them
to play catch with duck
the touch conscious face
anything in the world maybe you'll see
them again someday well from here on out
I'm gonna try and believe that - goddamn
feels it's gonna be different with him
he's gonna get raised right I won't make
the same mistakes again that's a promise
you should get back over by the fire
ain't no sense in both of us being over
here
I can handle watch on my own you should
come too
I don't know come on it'll be good for
everyone yeah okay yeah we did a press
bag we did it we're all a big party 360
hey party you sexy that doesn't make any
sense look at the transformer why not
see what we got here you miss TV come on
you miss you too late be honest let me
close I'm fine it's best to just get
this stuff out and open that's wrong
well that's fine but I can confirm there
was no time for kissing oh it's nice to
hear people laughing yeah it is you just
spend so much time trying to stay alive
you don't get a chance to enjoy living
yeah we need to make more time alcohol
helps hahaha
oh I forgot about him let me get that
bottom we got someone else that might
need some help yeah sounds like a wasted
good run Kenny today whose fault was
that that makes it even harder to deal
with
trust me Kenny please don't let it ruin
a nice night
I said my piece you always do I don't
think that voice a bad person
I just think good people do bad things
sometimes she did it too sorry okay
my fault I shouldn't use this
what do you do trying to pogies any home
it's okay it's okay
she's in a better place
maybe it's best if we all get some rest
who knows how long walk we have tomorrow
yeah that's a good idea I'll take first
watch
Thank You Kenny really I don't mention
it you did good he was nice while it
lasted
I was literally 30 seconds of happiness
and that was barely that's more than I
ever had in this meeting
goddamnit I don't really understand how
this is gonna end like we get to the
house and then what we're good yeah I'm
good
I start to crap out I'll let you know
okay will you do that it's no trouble
how much further close get close
you've been saying that every time I ask
that was close as [ __ ] did he get bit
that was close
no [ __ ] came out of nowhere I was real
loud hopefully there aren't more of them
yeah well let's move we don't want to be
around to find out it's very close come
should they learned not to go around
corners and stuff like that by now come
on what is that gonna do yeah and how
there's so much and it's not too shabby
we're here for the supplies not the
house it's portable fireplace
daddy boredom I'd just like a place to
sit if I'm honest it looks like it's
empty
yes it's empty I thought they're not so
to me now that he said that I'm not sure
if it ain't kids gonna wish it was
and we're gonna constantly maybe there's
a way around I don't see any more than
80 completely an American [ __ ] it's
okay
look I know [ __ ] ice that's the problem
he's saying it's fine I go first I can
be front
maybe we shouldn't come together we just
can't have too much weight she's right
we need to spread out just to be safe
no this is gonna be better one at a time
[ __ ] go first since he's so confident
uzuki if you're really worried you
should just crawl no no no no no no no
that ain't good daddy done Billy deunan
it's gonna crack it's gonna crack it's
gonna crack more than a crack [ __ ] Oh
God Clemmy can't crack she's like the
skinniest little girl I don't like this
pretentious I don't like what I don't go
circle uh-oh here it comes
can't they just test the eyes first ah
okay don't worry okay are those are
those oh my craft Kenny don't sit down
yeah God he's gonna don't run there you
go
why he's not really running how they did
it uh-oh somebody made it oh I am so on
ie Oh God a.m. yet
Oh No
throw away the gun Amy yeah get that out
of there like let me go you stupid ho
[Music]
stop telling her that flip look at me
hold on your gun
those day walkers okay just give me a
little time claim you can make it but
you need to go no no Clem this is too
dangerous
thanks thanks I'll be honest X just keep
shooting he looks like he can get out
Abby go they take two shots anyway
why can't [ __ ] off you batch oh my god
oh my god you guys are so stupid
good job bravo Bravo
[ __ ] Oh ten points you [ __ ] idiots
oh that has to be pretty [ __ ] cold
no no shut up oh my god
[Music]
come on
okay I got you
[ __ ] that you know what [ __ ] that let's
try that again
I don't want to [ __ ] lose Luke just
because a fluke that's why I have the
most subscribers god dammit
how is that even possible no come on
Bonnie stay the [ __ ] away you stupid
[ __ ] okay we're gonna help Luke there we
go no we gonna get Luke and it's gonna
be fine
just give me the gun and I'll drag you
up please don't die please don't die No
oh my god he dies anyway oh my god
Walker
what the [ __ ] I wait whale care get it
sorry
not the time I get it we're almost dying
here holy [ __ ]
where's the hole oh my god oh that feels
[Music]
by Luke
[ __ ] okay I got you I got you hit my
she's gonna be okay go to the house we
need a fire
god damn it
I really like Luke but ChaCha's it's
mija getting pills from the future god I
had the episode here as always they
always gotta end don't think but thank
you for liking this video bros as always
and thanks for hanging out with me today
stay awesome bros bro